c'est un petit bijou à 40 millions
d'euros le Clairefontaine du tir a vu le
jour en 2017 sur l'ancien site militaire
de La Martinerie les 100 hectares ont
retrouvé une nouvelle vie avec une
montée en puissance vers le rêve le plus
fou accueillir les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dans un an
dans ce dédale de couloir bureau et
gigantesque plateau de tir 23 salariés
œuvres au bon déroulement de toutes les
épreuves sportives et entraînement
là il y a énormément de compétition
cette année où on essaie vraiment de
mettre les bouchées doubles pour que ce
soit plus que parfait parce que
forcément on se sent observé donc là
vraiment on doit être plus que parfait
et c'est pour ça qu'on profite de chaque
occasion aussi pour donner le meilleur
de nous-mêmes dans les coulisses du
stand final un homme clé se cache
derrière son ordinateur c'est le
technicien de la ciblerie tout
électronique donc géré informatiquement
derrière donc oui c'est une grosse
machinerie pour faire un bon technicien
c'est deux ans de formation il faut être
très précis c'est qu'on a pas le droit à
l'erreur sur les temps sur l'ouverture
des sites fermeture des cibles monter
des résultats etc sur chaque stand 10 25
50 mètres et final 60 à 86 blocs sont à
vérifier au quotidien
on va vérifier chaque face avant si elle
est si elle était touchée ou pas touchée
si elle est touchée on la change et
après on va vérifier on a des
récupérateurs de plomb on va les vider
s'ils sont pleines et on va faire un
petit nettoyage si elles sont trop
encrassées elle les plomb comme tous les
résidus de tirs métaux et plastique sont
donc récupérés et recyclés depuis son
ouverture le site veut être
éco-responsable ça tombe bien c'est dans
le cahier des charges de Paris 204
donc là on se trouve dans le couloir
où on retrouve toutes les machines pour
la fausse olympique et pour la fausse
olympique on a 15 machines parfois les
plateaux sont en composite et bio
dégradables ils sont lancés à la demande
des tireurs dans leur discipline la
fosse olympique et le skate
mais en prévision des JO le centre va
devoir s'adapter
[Musique]
là par exemple dans le stand final on a
justement les assises qui vont être des
fêtes et on va augmenter le nombre de
places assises donc il va falloir
déplacer toute toutes ces sièges ensuite
on a la tribune du trapenskip on va
décevoir enlever la toiture et augmenter
donc la capacité avec une tribune
éphémère de 1200 places voilà c'est
plein de petites choses comme ça le
premier joie 2024 le comité
d'organisation prendra ses quartiers au
CNTs et le compensera financièrement des
trois mois sans autre activité toutes
les équipes locales deviendront alors
bénévoles d'ici là les équipes de France
ils multiplient les entraînements
c'est un privilège pour les athlètes
c'est sûr après il faut qu'on en fasse
le Home advance en fait s'en servir pour
avoir ce petit avantage sur les équipes
étrangères qui nous demandent depuis
quelques mois à venir s'entraîner ici
alors on les accepte on encadrait
énormément leur venue pour garder ce
petit avantage et s'entraîner
régulièrement sur ces installations où
on espère qu'on entendra raisonner la
Marseillaise dans quelques mois et
peut-être le 27 juillet 2024 c'est
toujours le tir sportif qui décerne la
première médaille d'or des jeux ce sera
bien à Châteauroux
[Musique]